[Music]
today's question comes from caleb in
ohio
i'm a skilled trades apprentice and
currently make 30 an hour
i'm married to a beautiful wife and we
have a 10 month old baby ever since the
coveted lockdown started my wife has
been left unemployed she went to college
and has a degree in psychology i can
work overtime at my job and could
potentially bring it home
an extra thousand to fifteen hundred
dollars a month we are
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars in
debt including our mortgage
she loves staying home with the baby but
i think it would be highly beneficial
for her to have a good
paying job should she get a job
i feel like my chest get tight oh this
sounds like a
fight yeah yeah well first okay i want
to challenge one thing at the beginning
of this
uh since coveted lockdowns she's been
left unemployed
there are job opportunities people are
hurting
for employees everywhere all the time
and
she has the potential to do something on
her own so it's not that there's not an
opportunity out there i want to
challenge that
first of all that's true the issue is
she had been looking for an opportunity
because she would stay home
she's like oh there's nothing out there
babe sorry i checked i checked
i worked on it for like a minute and a
half today there's nothing there's
nothing out there shucks i'm gonna have
to stay home with this adorable baby
barn
yeah try it again yeah you know what's
interesting is and this is like so many
questions we get dave
is it's a values question more than a
money question yes there's a financial
piece of it if she got a job you all
would get out of debt faster that's a
that's a
financial mathematical equation but but
then you look at the cost of child care
too it would have to be something that
makes more
than what you're paying in child care to
make sense if you
are paying for child care which is a
major variable
in there but i think it's interesting
too because the idea of women staying
home
is something that is extremely um what's
the word
emotionally triggering polarizing people
have a lot of opinions on
um i don't know yeah i think they have
two opinions in that house
he wants her to go to work she doesn't
want to yeah um
so that's problem number one yeah uh you
guys need to get on the same page on
that
because i got a feeling caleb you
completely stacked this
this whole question i mean here's an
example caleb
how you how badly you screwed up your
intent here um
we're 180 000 in debt including our
mortgage
so what 179 000 of it's the mortgage we
don't know
you completely stacked that we're so
deeply in debt is what you're trying to
say and that's a bunch of crap i'm
calling you on it we're sinking dave
send her to work
sit tell her she she needs to go to the
salt mines
now but the uh all right so here's the
thing
uh i think the first thing you two need
to agree on
is if we can afford it and our family is
going to be okay
are we on the same page that she stays
home yeah
and you're not there yeah and that's so
i'm reading in between the lines old
caleb wants to go to work
even if they were millionaires 100 and
what's so important about that piece of
it
is that if you're not on the same page
and you continue to function this way
you're going to resent her
yeah she's getting tired of being
treated like she's lazy
caleb you're gonna mistakenly think that
she does nothing all day
and let me tell you right now a baby is
not a vacation and she she does
work it's just at home so that's the
first piece of but if she does go to
work
to make him happy she's gonna resent
that so getting on the same page to
avoid the resentment building up between
you guys is going to be so important
so at what number at what point in your
finances
are you both going to be in agreement
because right now there's not any number
i can read it in here i don't believe
there's a number
and you caleb you need to determine at
what point
you are comfortable with her staying
home
and if that's never you need to look in
the mirror
okay so uh that's an issue because she
your wife has said i want to stay home
with a kid
and uh this is your kid your wife so
that's an issue
to just declare everyone who stays home
with a kid lazy regardless of the
numbers
is pretty much asinine and caleb so um
you know that's not that's not an option
you can't put that on the table here uh
and so now if she wants to work
that's a whole different story
absolutely and and if she wants to work
no matter what
the income is um that's a different
story too
and so uh i mean in your case you you've
got three kids
uh you enjoy being a ramsey personality
in the work time
it's a lot of hours sometimes and matt
makes plenty of money yeah you would you
easily could stay home yeah yeah but you
do you get fulfillment here
and have chosen that yeah uh and so
that's a that's a completely different
equation too
but and rachel too yeah my daughter one
of your best
friends the same thing so um
but but so anyway now at what point can
she stay home if you guys can pay your
bills
and you can eat and you can move ahead
and i'm thinking you can with what you
make in ohio
then if she wants to stay home
mathematically i think she probably can
now or you could set some interim goals
that says
okay once we hit this break then we're
going to
make that call once we finish off the
non-mortgage debt
yeah then we'll make that call or
something like that
what's interesting too that i'd be and
i'm sure if they if they went to
counseling about this i'm sure counselor
would actually dig into it but i wonder
what
the hang up is for caleb it might be
financial it may not there may be
something where it's like there's a
level of
expectation that he sees and work ethic
or something you need to dig into and
unpack and deconstruct and get on the
same page
that it's not just a number because your
point there may not be a number it may
be something else in him
that is a hang up and so y'all getting
on the same page there it's going to be
so so important that's how it sounds in
the in the email to me well and
one more thing on that that's one of the
things i love helping women do with
business boutique because a lot of women
in our business boutique audience in my
coaching group that come to the event
they have that desire to stay home but
have a desire to do something else and
they don't want to work a traditional
nine to five in an office job so they
start a business from home during nap
hours so
there's also other options between her
just working
50 hours a week outside the home so just
she might make more than
at that than something else too yes by
the way absolutely yeah a lot of the
ladies in business boutique do
yes